tom and donna and april and terry left
when i looked around this office
nothing was the same
yeah well there's a way to fix that
[Music]
laugh with me
buddy
just with me
buddy
don't let her get the best of me
buddy
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
if i
ever needed you
buddy
you know now
i really do
but
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
[Music]
well this is different from what i
expected to find
morning guys good morning leslie
what did you do to the office ron you're
wearing my yoga clothes you're going to
stretch out the elastic we're sorry
[Music]
lots of people think that stanley
hudson's amino grump
but
would a grump make this
it's me
[Music]
it's me
and now we're all sleeping in one room
next to a cow orgy i'd much rather be
hanging out with you what are you doing
boyle you're just brushing my hair not
you becca i was talking to charles i was
just bringing you some water thanks
mm-hmm so uh
are you talking to is that your mystery
hunk babe are you all right is
everything okay yeah it's fine i'll call
you back later is that a woman's voice
it's my sister wait
she called you babe well my cousin
called me babe you said relatives
shouldn't do that
what's really going on
i'm dating a woman
i'm bi oh that's great
that's great roy i just want you to know
that i totally is important i want to
talk about it right now okay just leave
it alone boyle by all means not you
becca
love you
i love you too
hey
hey
so
i didn't say anything about being bi
because i didn't think it was anybody's
business
and i also didn't want anything to
change i get it i'm sorry i'm so nosy
actually felt really good to tell
somebody on the squad finally
i'm glad it was you all right
also now we go back to never talking
about my love life again uh request
tonight is your name ann meredith kim
erica moana you guys you guys be cool
what's going on i kind of convinced ben
to prank you guys and it got a little
out of hand i probably should have said
no to some of his ideas but he's on his
way here right now here he is just be
cool
hey guys what's up
um
oh i just remembered can i show you
something out to the front area and
leave your cell phones uh because of no
reason just
leave anything that can't get wet
actually like you would normally
okay here we go to the parking lot now
wow this is really sad
yep follow it to me guys just go into
the parking lot for normal government
reasons
sorry i can't go through with this i was
gonna pull a prank
no yeah i hired these guys in ski masks
to kidnap us and i was gonna pretend to
be a hero they were gonna shoot me and
drive the van into the river and that's
when the divers would go in pull you
guys out of the water and i would be
standing on the shore like hey get
pranked much what the
i even got these squibs from a special
effects guy and i was gonna say this
code word that's when i would push this
button no no
oh my god you got blood all over me
thank you
i mean it
ben that was amazing really best prank
ever
come to parking lot
crazy pigeon action
you're gonna scare him away
that's a text yeah right
that's your new standard
i am screwed up depressed amy's been
doing her best to cheer me up she gave
me the sticker this morning just for
waking up yeah it's like you're dating
your teacher i know it's so hot
meanwhile holt won't even talk to me how
is he by the way honestly terrible i've
only heard from him once this week and
that was to tell me he'd finally come up
with a new non-threatening term for task
forces y'all ready for this
do groups wow that sucks tremendously
can i have another port you're still
drinking that stuff yeah hulk got me
hooked on it i even got a bottle for my
house it's really classing up the booze
and take out menu's shelf
wait a minute
i think i just figured something out i
gotta go aren't you forgetting something
uh
no pay your bill
damn who raised you hey ron
can i ask you a question
sure it's about april
i don't like to get involved in people's
personalities i hurt her feelings
and now she's pissed at me
i feel like if i could just explain
myself she'd understand but she's
avoiding me
it's making me miserable
april's in the hospital sick with the
flu what
i knew it
i didn't know that is she okay yeah
she's fine
you can go visit her tomorrow morning
but don't tell her i told her i won't
no no no no
come on
who did this to you
where is he
what
no it's not
it's nothing
it's hot in here
yeah
thanks
i you don't need to stay here i know
so you're pmsing pretty bad huh
what's going on family game night don't
worry i brought twister
hey rosa hey frozen there was the snacks
you know in another lifetime you and i
would have made a hot ass couple agreed
yes you should be very proud of yourself
i know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but uh
i promise you they will approve
thank you captain every time someone
steps up and says who they are
the world becomes a better more
interesting place
so
thank you
so i guess we are celebrating that
you trusted me and i let you down great
i changed my house locks every 16 days
that key has been useless since the
second tuesday after i gave it to you
what matters is that i trust you
and admire you as a person
i will be sorry to see you leave this
town for many reasons
not the least of which is that you
created a puzzle that even i couldn't
solve
and boy oh boy
did you love andy
woof woof
angela someone wants you
okay i'm coming
hi baby angela's divorce from the
senator
has been very difficult for her when she
got kicked out of her apartment
i invited her to move in with me
ironic that now it's angela who's living
in the closet
hello
saddle shoes with denim
i will literally call child protective
services
you